kenosha
smolders a city corrections building
burnt to the ground
one of three dozen buildings left in
ruins in a single night
firefighters and residents sweep up the
wreckage
i am with the black lives matter
movement i'm you know
i've been protesting and i'm not with
this this is my community
phillip mary arrived to find the windows
of his 92 year old office
smashed but it was largely spared
his neighbor wasn't so lucky how
senseless it is
to vandalize
someone's property the mother of jacob
blake the black man whose shooting by
police set off the demonstrations
says he would not approve if jacob
knew what was going on as far as that
goes
the violence and the destruction
he would be very unpleased
blake's family spoke of the latest
incident of alleged police brutality
captured in this viral video of an
officer shooting him in the back
his three sons watching from inside the
car
i shot my son
seven times seven times
like he didn't matter but my son matters
blake's attorneys say he underwent
surgery on tuesday and remains
paralyzed from the waist down i'm not
sad
i'm not sorry i'm angry
and i'm tired i haven't cried one
time i stopped crying years ago
i am numb i have been watching police
murder people that look like me for
years
as her family struggles with what
happened so does a battered city
well police were protecting government
buildings the looters came here to the
uptown neighborhood
and they fire bombed and looted each of
the stores for a couple of blocks
until they got here to kingdom ward
ministries that's where david montgomery
is pastor
actually we had somebody actually take a
big large rock
and throw it through the window and we
started yelling hey this is a
church and i heard several people say
hey you don't
touch a church you know and one of the
firemen said
hey pastor it looks like your your
building is going to be the only thing
that's saved
you know and it's just a miracle from
god
one building salvaged amid dozens of
burnt out hulls
and more broken hearts john hendren al
jazeera
kenosha wisconsin